- I'm just thinking about,
well I'm thinking about a lot
of stories and things that
happened you know.
I remember when we were together,
you had your amazing dogs,
Flossy and Templeton,
and Vivian.
- Yeah.
- I remember one time it was Christmas,
and you came up to Canada to my parents'
house for Christmas, and,
I flew Flossy up to Canada for Christmas
and didn't tell you,
you were sitting on the floor
of the house that I grew up in
as a kid, and I opened the
door and Flossy walked out,
and I remember you looking at Flossy,
and you thought,
"Oh, there's a dog that
looks like Flossy."
And then you realized it was Flossy,
and it was very cute.
And so, I sort of had this
lifelong love of dogs now,
because of Flossy and
Templeton and Vivian, yeah.
- Well, we had that house fire,
and Flossy saved us and
got us out of the house,
and we're standing up
on the top of the hill.
The house was in the canyons.
And when I'm watching the,
telephone poles explode,
and the house was a barn,
it was built out of wood, wood,
floors, walls, and ceiling.
So it went like an Acme cartoon.
It just sort of like,
the fire went through the
house and then it crumbled.
And I was just standing
there in such shock,
and I was looking down and just going,
"Okay I just hope this doesn't
ravage anybody else's homes.
Like this one's gone and that's that."
And you leaned into my ear
and you started singing,
♪ Da na na na na na na na na na ♪
The Entertainment Tonight theme.
And it's like when your whole life--
- Well I think the media
had assembled outside
in front of the house.
It was obviously a horrible situation.
- But it made me laugh--
- I felt so bad.
- In that moment that
everything was so dark,
and scary and confusing,
and you lightened it up for me.
You made me laugh.
And I will never forget that.
In the middle of what was
such a terrifying moment,
there's this one little light in it.
And it's you making me giggle so hard,
in the middle of this
darkness came this light,
and it was you.
We just had so many crazy adventures and,
in some ways having lived such
a public life, my whole life,
I still was in new territory
with what you were doing with
yours.
You were bringing cameras into everywhere.
Nobody was doing this.
This was not...
Not only, not normal in the funnest way,
but it was unprecedented.
I mean, you've been
doing podcasts for years,
before podcasts were a thing.
And now you're taking
a podcast, on the road.
- Right now I've just...
Charlie and I we're about to
go take off on an adventure,
crew.
We're going across the country in a van.
Charlie and I are moving
into a van next week.
And we're gonna go out into the beautiful,
emptiness of America,
lots of places that people haven't been,
some of the beautiful places
that people don't get to see,
and I'm gonna be doing my
podcast out of this van.
And, kind of much like
what you're doing here,
this burst of optimism and
positivity that you bring to TV
every day.
I kinda wanted to do something
where we went out and
celebrated, the great things
about America, right now,
'cause there's a lot of
negativity in the world and,
I became an American citizen last year.
I don't know if I told you that.
- Congratulation.
(audience cheers and claps)
- So,
yeah.
So--
- And it's a better country for it.
- I made it.
- Thank you Tom.
- Do you like my mug?
- I do. Oh my God.
Is that me with a neck brace on?
- Oh,
(Drew laughs)
Oh,
Oh yeah.
- Oh my God.
- Oh yeah.
That's you with a neck brace on.
I found this...
(Tom giggles)
I found this mug in my
garage, a couple years ago
and I just kinda kept it,
'cause I figured someday
I might be on your TV show
and it'd be fun to have
a sip out of the mug.
- Well, the tables have turned,
now I have the cameras on you Tom.
- Yup. Yup.
Remember the day in New
York, you were doing yoga,
you sprained your neck.
- Yeah.
- And then Chris went and made...
Chris made these mugs, and somehow,
I kept the mug.
all these years, I've kept the mug, so.
- I'm so happy to see you.
And in the words of Patty
Smith, we were just kids.
- Yes. Yes.
We were.
We were in our twenties, and,
now I'm not in my twenties anymore, but--
- Where does the time go?
- Yeah, we had a lot of
amazing, amazing experiences,
and I'm grateful for that
and I cherish them and,
thanks Drew, I appreciate it.
- I cherish you right back.
- Thanks drew.
- Thank you Tom.
I wanna mention that the Tom
Green interview on Apple,
Spotify, or wherever you
listen to podcasts is out.
It will be available.
I suggest you go through a
library of Tom Green when,
you need it most or you
just wanna feel good.
All right?
(upbeat music)